chinas partei und staatschef sheikh ist
der pate für diesen krieg in der ukraine
muss man sagen
putin hat ja die invasion erst begonnen
nachdem shipping im so eine art
freifahrtschein gegeben hat also bei der
eröffnung der olympischen spiele haben
die beiden sicher getroffen haben eine
gemeinsame erklärung verabschiedet die
mit einem takt gleichzusetzen ist die
haben da das gleiche weltbild und es
wurde genau die argumente die russland
hatte wurden übernommen und so jetzt
sagen alle bei uns oder viele bei uns in
der politik das ist ja völlig
überraschend dass das jetzt so passiert
es nein es ist nicht überraschend dass
hat sich in den letzten jahren
entwickelt shipping ist zum mächtigsten
mann der welt geworden und tutin ist
sein juniorpartner und die beiden haben
nie einen zweifel daran gelassen hier in
hilter ausgemacht dass sie gegen
freiheit und gegen demokratie sind in
hongkong in taiwan und in der ukraine
und wir sprechen jetzt über unsere über
große abhängigkeit von russland aber
unsere abhängigkeit von china ist ja
noch viel viel größer darüber müssen wir
mal diskutieren und müssen endlich wach
werden und unsere freiheit verteidigen
wir sind in der tat sehr abhängig von
china gerade in wirtschaftlicher
hinsicht wenn man sich mal anschaut was
die deutschen autobauer wie vw bmw auch
wie daimler in china verkaufen da muss
man leider feststellen
ohne china würden auch hier in
deutschland viele arbeitsplätze verloren
gehen und würden auch viele
steuereinnahmen fehlen also die deutsche
industrie hat sich ja fast so eine art
bypass in china gelegt und lebt deswegen
von china und wir was jetzt viele
registrieren ja nicht nur in der politik
oder hierbei bild oder auch in der
deutschen gesellschaft insgesamt sondern
vor allem auch in der deutschen
industrie ist dass diese geopolitischen
punkte die sie eben angesprochen haben
doch ein größeres risiko bedeuten als
man es vermutet hatte weil vorher haben
ja ganz viele gesagt also vor dem
angriffskrieg von putin auf die ukraine
ja das ist ein schwieriger partner aber
gas und öl liest immer das war auch
schon zur zeit der sowjetunion so und
auch mit china wird das ähnlich sein und
da sind jetzt vielen die augen auch
geöffnet worden deswegen wird das dazu
führen aus meiner sicht dass sich gerade
auch die unternehmen versuchen
unabhängiger natürlich von russland aber
auch von china aufzustellen und da kann
ich auch nur sagen das ist auch gut so
ja es gibt ja ein zitat das lenin
unterstellt wird dass die
kapitalisten in ihrer profitgier den
kommunisten noch den strick verkaufen
mit dem sie dann aufgehängt werden also
es umstritten ob linien das wirklich
gesagt hat aber im falle chinas ist ja
genau das
passiert in dieser gier nach diesem
großen chinesischen markt mit 1,4
milliarden menschen haben volkswagen und
siemens haben apple und microsoft die
ganze produktion nach china verlagert
und haben das war immer die bedingungen
für all diese joint ventures ich meine
dabei die chinesische führung sehr
schlau ist eine harmlose muss rein damit
man gründen darf natürlich der chinese
yao sowieso haben das war immer auch die
bedingung
know-how-transfer also dass immer die
westlichen firmen auch den china das
know-how geben mussten und damit haben
sie china stark gemacht und haben haben
shipping stark gemacht ja nicht nur das
sondern natürlich auch die bevölkerung
in eine viel bessere situation gebracht
als sie vorher gewesen ist also der
benefit der wirtschaftlichen entwicklung
ist ja der chinesischen bevölkerung
massiv zu gute gekommen und die frage
die man sich stellen muss ist und die
stelle ich auch deshalb weil wir mit
chinesen zusammenarbeiten seit acht
jahren und ich mir das immer wieder ich
möchte dass immer wieder fragt ist es
richtig auf der wirtschafts ebene so zu
arbeiten und damit die menschen auch zu
gewinnen in unseren werten so wie wir
uns das vorstellen
oder ist es richtig zu sagen ich möchte
in einem politischen system dass meine
werte nicht teilt gar nicht aufschlagen
ich will damit nichts zu tun haben und
nach den acht jahren erfahrungen bin ich
fest davon überzeugt dass mit den
mitarbeitern die wii nach deutschland
holen unsere mitarbeit in china gehen
haben wir eine kleine plattform 240
mitarbeiter bei dem flugzeug programm
ist es eine kleine plattform aber
nichtsdestotrotz entwickelt sich ein
verständnis ein gegenseitiges und
deshalb sicher in einer vielzahl von
unternehmen entwickelt und da sehen wir
ja das was wir jetzt in russland auch
sehen wir haben eine politik deren werte
wir nicht teilen und wir haben aber ein
wirtschaftliches handeln das in einem
gleichen werteverständnis stattfindet
nämlich natürlich orientiert an dem
erfolg der unternehmen ganz klare
zieldefinition und jetzt frage ich was
sollen wir machen sollen was lassen und
den kontakt von vornherein wird ja das
wird ja nicht funktionieren weil wir
haben ja lupenreinen demokratien nach
unserem vorbild gibt es in der ganzen
welt nur sehr wenige also unser modell
ist ja nicht das was die welt dominiert
und wir merken ja auch autoritäre
ansätze die haben ja in vielen regionen
der welt leider wieder konjunktur und
deswegen teile ich das dass wir handeln
durch handel und wandel durch handel
vorantreiben müssen weil sich dadurch
natürlich einiges auch entwickelt
kulturell zwischen ländern um
verständnis füreinander da ist und doch
manches auch eine richtige richtung sich
bewegt dafür gibt's ja auch in der
geschichte beispiele das was wir jetzt
mit russland erleben ist natürlich das
negativste beispiel dass wir in der
jüngeren vergangenheit überhaupt erlebt
haben aber es gibt auch sehr viel
positivbeispiele und daher halte ich
schon für richtig dass man auch nicht
nur sagt wir handeln jetzt mit
demokratien und bauen außenbeziehungen
auf zu demokratie
ich fange mal allein mit
kann er nicht selber sagen dass er damit
wir alle einmal in die diskussion einmal
abgeholt haben denn groß sehen sie
gesehen ich auf sie achte beste
generälen zeitpunkt haben das ist
freundlich ja solche großzügigkeit
die situation und da möchte ich von
tonia diesen teil schon eine antwort
geben auf ihre frage das war eine sehr
interessante frage die sie gestellt wird
und ich antworte mit adenauer die crew
jörg schumann einer geschwungenen
weltkriegs generation durch zwei
weltkriegen die gesagt haben friede er
nur durch wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
und zwar unterschiedlicher länder auch
unterschiedliche entwicklungsstufen und
ich glaube das ist auch in diesem fall
die richtige antwort friede nur durch
wirtschaftlicher zusammenhang der
zusammenarbeit bedeutet aber auch
abhängigkeit das ist dann die kehrseite
der medaille
und da soll man sich nicht in den sack
lügen wir wollten zb die letzten jahre
mit russland selbstverständlich diese
abhängigkeit wenn wir damit frieden und
zusammenarbeit schaffen wollten und sind
jetzt enttäuscht weil sich die situation
anders entwickelt haben als wir uns das
dorf mit unserer mentalität in europa
vorgestellt im übrigen weil wir auch da
und und blind worden und da die signale
auf die letzten 20 jahren nicht gehört
haben und jetzt das große wunder da ist
gottes wille sehr schwierig aber okay
lassen wir das beiseite wir das
diskutieren wir nicht diskutieren wir
was passiert wenn du wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit wie jetzt zum beispiel
mit russland auf kündigt aber weiß dass
auf die these vom herrn autor china den
wirtschaftskreis von russland bilder es
bedeutet in volt das wieder sanktionen
als europäische union helmut rösseler
grünen tisch verordnet haben und
russland in wahrheit längst einen
wirtschaftskreis mit china indien und
pakistan gebildet haben und die
sanktionen ausschließlich uns selbst
pressen und zwar im höchsten ausmaße
treibstoffpreise heizölpreise
lebensmittelpreise etc
und wie er noch immer nicht darauf
kommen dass wir was das betrifft auf
einem kompletten holzweg sind wir müssen
die emotionen und die enttäuschung dass
frieden ein krieg geworden ist und
zerstören gewöhnlichen müssen das auch
mal zurücknehmen ein wenig die emotion
ich auch verstehen und wieder vernünftig
zu einer zusammenarbeit kommen wir
werden auch mit russland wieder zu einer
vernünftigen zusammenarbeit kommen
müssen wir tun uns ja auch mit china und
wie vor ort um die tiefen tal richtige
weise gesagte werte chinas entsprechen
nicht unbedingt unseren werten von
demokratie
beide seiten verlieren
natürlich ist es richtig und hat
unterschreiben wir übrigens auch unsere
buchstäblich der mächtigste mann der
welt natürlich ist es richtig dass sich
china in den letzten jahren gewaltig
entwickelt hat auch zum wohl der
bevölkerung dort dass das hunderte
millionen menschen dort aus der aus der
armut befreit worden sind das ist auch
eine gewaltige leistung nur das ist ja
nicht die leistung der kommunistischen
partei das fing ja nicht an mit der
kommunistischen revolution 949 sondern
das viel an
1978 mit der reform und öffnung als
china sich für
marktwirtschaftliche methoden geöffnet
hat als china ausländisches kapital ins
land geholt hat so das ist ja alles gut
dass sich das entwickelt hat ich bin
auch nicht führen dass man jetzt die
beziehungen zu china abbricht weil da
kein handel mehr treibt oder so etwas
mir geht es darum dass genauso wie china
offensiv seine interessen vertritt
müssen wir offensiv unsere interessen
vertreten denn was ich gezeigt hat dass
durch handel alleine sich an den
verhältnissen dort nichts ändern
deswegen auch den kulturellen aber immer
so helfen jedem aber das machen wir
endlich mal unsere eigenen interessen
abstecken dann müssen wir uns klar sein
welche interessen haben wie in europa
ich habe den eindruck dass sowohl
außenpolitisch heißt auch
sicherheitspolitisch als auch
wirtschaftspolitisch wir als europa
keine eigenständigen interessen
vertreten sondern jedes mal darauf
warten dass der europarat auf ausgabe
lief station weißes haus in washington
bei uns anruft und uns erklärt wie wir
europäer zu denken wie wir zu handeln
wir sind dann nützlich video der usa
gerade die jahren hätten ja die große
chance bedeutet eine eigenständige
wirtschafts außen und sicherheitspolitik
zu machen und nicht zu regulieren
zwischen usa und ghana sind wir haben
nein denn ich glaube sie möchten darauf
antworten das ist vermintes gebiet weil
ich glaube dass wir in der zeit von
trump gesehen haben dass sich ein
weiterer autor oka autokrat auf den weg
gemacht hat und gott sei dank hat er
keine zweite amtszeit gehabt und das ist
haarscharf ausgegangen sie haben völlig
recht europa muss sich formen und muss
natürlich 1 1 ein erkennbares ein
erkennbarer vertreter dieser diese
dieser zeit seien und nicht so
auseinander geteilt haben wir noch viel
zu tun aber ich denke wir sind in
demselben dilemma mit china wie wir das
mit russland waren und überall dort wo
sich einzelne menschen das recht
herausnehmen das land auszubeuten
korrupt zu sein zu ihrem eigenen vorteil
politik zu betreiben weil wir müssen das
doch beim namen nennen es ist ja wir
reden von einem putin in russland wir
reden von einem erdogan in der türkei
wir reden in ungarn in polen die jetzt
natürlich das ist ein bisschen in
vergessenheit geraten auch auf dem weg
dorthin waren und in china ist glaube
ich die situation ein bisschen anders
weil da die partei doch mehr drum rum
ist um diesen führer als das
ist ganz ganz entschieden und erntet das
ist genau die änderung mit shipping es
gibt so ein personenkult um shipping
also das aber nicht allein hin zu
mauerzeiten es geht ja bis dahin dass
ihnen kirchen es gibt auch bei christen
in china nicht viele aber dass dein
kirchen die marien bilder abgehängt
werden mussten unterschiedlichen bilder
ersetzt werden dass die leute auch mit
digitalen methoden dass sie neue das
recht auf leben nochmal eigentlich will
noch einmal auf einen unterschied
hinweisen weil jetzt glaube ich einiges
auch vermischt wird russland china
einige in der debatte bringen dann ja
auch noch katar ein da sind natürlich
alles keine demokratie nach unserem
vorbild völlig klar aber russland hat
einen angriffskrieg auf ein anderes land
begonnen und das ist noch der große
unterschied im moment zu china ist auch
der unterschied zur qatar oder venezuela
und deswegen ist das ja wenn man so will
im moment auch die chance von ländern
wie katar von venezuela auch von china
dass die wieder stärker aufs spielfeld
kommen und russland ersetzen weil
russland rausgenommen wird weil das land
ein angriffskrieg begangen hat und daher
muss man auch noch etwas unterscheiden
und ich bin genau dafür was er gesagt
hat dass wir stärker als europäer unsere
interessen wahrnehmen dass wir auch
stärker zusammen agieren das können wir
übrigens gegenüber großmächten wie china
gegenüber großmächten wie russland oder
auch gegenüber großmächten wie den usa
nur schaffen wenn wir alle zusammen
halten wenn du dann bringen wir gewicht
auf die weltpolitische waage aber wir
dürfen wir auch in der dürnau dürfen
auch nicht den fehler machen und zu
sagen wir handeln jetzt nur noch mit
staaten die unseren demo tischen und
westlichen standards entsprechen das
wird in der weltpolitik nicht
funktioniert zur überhaupt nicht aber es
geht noch das leiten wir
das irgendwie also ich freue mich wie
lebendig die diskussion über china als
ich dachte eigentlich gesagt das thema
wenn nicht so lebendig ist es aber dem